anyway our secretary of state Anthony
blinken went on television yesterday and
uh he welcomed Sweden and Finland into
NATO so that is one thing that happened
in the last couple days uh and he tells
Putin and he ain't gonna win this thing
man
let's start we know Sweden is now
following Finland into NATO what message
do you think that this will send to
Russia what message do you want it to
send if any
well it sends two messages first of all
our alliance is stronger it's bigger
with two new members Finland and now
Sweden and it's more united than ever
and in terms of Russia's aggression
against Ukraine it's sending a very
strong message to Putin that he's not
going to outlast us he's not going to
outlast
I mean it's just meaningless dribble
like that okay I have no inherent
problem with Sweden and Finland getting
in NATO but do you think Sweden and
Finland you think Putin woke up this
morning like uh oh oh oh Sweden and
Finland are in the NATO what am I going
to do get me some vodka so I can think
about this like he's been at war in
essence with the United States and
Ukraine you think it's gonna the thing
that's gonna turn the war around or a
bunch of Finnish soldiers on the border
of Russia like it's just this is what we
do with everything it like all sounds
good blinking it sounds good we'll have
a bigger broader Coalition except nobody
does anything everyone does jack
except for the United States that's how
it works so if we don't do anything
nothing happens and if we do do
something something happens good or bad
that's how it is
[Music]